[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance today every day the
presidential administration of Donald
John Trump looks a little bit more than
it did the day before like a bomb
disposal operation and the Republican
Party owns the bomb our alliances are in
tatters the president gives away Intel
to whomever he wants his budget proposal
has a two trillion dollar math error the
Germans say Europe must go on without us
Trump wanders off a stage in Israel
shoves aside one European leader and all
but arm wrestles another starts
spontaneously boasting about the Montana
congressional outcome in Sicily offers
to trade personal cell phone numbers
with the new French president is
believed to be angry at the EU because
it was so difficult for him to build
golf courses there
the Russians reportedly boast of having
had financial leverage against Trump
during the campaign and words like
collusion and corruption and emoluments
in espionage and treason echo across the
country and Trump identifies the true
enemy
the news media and on and on and on
and nearly all the Republicans say
nothing as if they cannot hear the
ticking of the bomb the few who speak
nearly all Buck passed back with a tepid
you'll have to ask the White House or
they offer transparently asinine
rationalizations for a growingly unfit
president who threatens the freedom and
the safety of every American and indeed
of every living thing on this planet as
if letting the bomb go off is just one
of a series of debatable political
options I warned the leaders of the
Republican Party Donald Trump's
candidacy was his fault Donald Trump's
election no matter how much the Russians
aided it was this broken society's fault
Donald Trump's supporters are
everybody's fault
but Republicans Donald Trump's continued
presidency is entirely your fault and
unless this man actually manages to
literally destroy this country or this
world this simultaneous nightmare shared
by hundreds of millions here and abroad
will forever damned you in history
Republicans just as the Democrats who
were willing to sell out our freedom
during the Civil War are damned in
history just as the southerners of all
parties who sanctioned Jim Crow are
damned in history just as the traitors
in law or indeed throughout our national
life are damned in history Donald Trump
might as well be a Russian spy or have
been clinically diagnosed with any of a
thousand psychological illnesses were
diseased or in an altered state of
consciousness or the specifics almost no
longer matter in just over four months
in power he has virtually erased
historical comparison he is beyond Nixon
he is beyond Woodrow Wilson after his
paralyzing stroke he's beyond the
afflicted King George if there's anybody
to whom he can now be compared perhaps
it's the disastrous first century Roman
Emperor Nero an all trite trump
supporter echoes the campaign and hurls
abuse at two teenage girls one wearing a
hit job on a commuter train and two
American heroes one from the political
right and one from the political left
intervened to save them and they are
killed for doing so and Trump ignores it
for more than three days but finds time
to tweet about the news media being the
enemy Paul Ryan you don't hear the bomb
ticking to hell with you now you own the
bomb Ryan the Republican chair of
Multnomah County and Oregon says that to
protect his Republican staffers in
public maybe he should hire right-wing
militia like the oathkeepers or the
three percenters as quote security orrin
hatch you don't hear the bomb ticking to
hell with you now you own the bomb hatch
Trump tells the butcher of the
Philippines about our nuclear subs near
North Korea he blows the cover of
Israel's vital Isis lead to the Russians
and somebody gives away the details of
the Manchester terrorist attack to the
newspapers John McCain you don't hear
the bomb ticking to hell with you now
you own the bomb McCain the Kushner
family all what offers to sell green
cards to rich Chinese who will
invest in their private real estate
deals the Russians reportedly say
Kushner wanted to use their spy
communication systems to talk directly
to the Kremlin and he reportedly meets
with a banker tied to Russian espionage
George W Bush you don't hear the bomb
ticking to hell with you now you own the
bomb bush Trump attacks a late night
television host the windows of a
newspaper office are shot out in
Kentucky a reporter is arrested after
asking a question of the Secretary of
Health and Human Services
another is body slammed by a congressman
to be the night before the election the
president meets with the Russians in the
Oval Office
no American media is admitted a
protester is convicted of laughing at
the testimony of the Attorney General
the president tweets about news the
enemy Hugh Hewitt you don't hear the
bomb ticking to hell with you now you
own the bomb Hewitt long ago Trump lost
any hope of controlling himself the
Republicans who could get him out of
office with the 25th amendment before
sunrise do nothing as Churchill once
said they go on in strange paradox
decided only to be undecided resolved to
be irresolute adamant for drift solid
for fluidity all-powerful to be
impotence Republicans you don't hear the
bomb ticking to hell with you
now you own the bomb Republicans on the
21st of April 156 years ago a failed
soldier farmer bill collector and
firewood salesman wrote his father a
letter whatever may have been my
political opinions before I have but one
sentiment now he wrote that is we have a
government and laws and a flag and they
must all be sustained there are but two
parties now traitors and Patriots I want
hereafter to be ranked with the latter
and I trust the stronger party the
writer was ulysses s grant and he was
explaining to his father why when he had
finally just gotten up on his feet in
civilian life
he now had to go back to the army
because on that 21st of April 1861 there
were indeed but two parties traitors and
Patriots and as this our modern-day Nero
tweets while a nation burns those who
are not patriots salt away all the
financial spoils they can grab and roll
back every statue of progress they can
repeal and exploit every fear they can
locate and put every dollar they can
find into the pockets of the
corporations which own them and the bomb
and the White House continues to tick
and the infamy continues to adhere more
and more strongly to the party at which
we will one day soon look back and say
they could have stopped this the reality
is simple and it requires the general
Grant's letter to his father be altered
by only the measure of one pair of words
there are but two parties now
Republicans and Americans resist peace